and we continue to tackle the rent
crisis here in the valley today you'll
meet a resident who says she's trapped
living a nightmare inside of an old
apartment Christian gasadas has her
story and also how she says she's
trapped because she can't afford to move
out
Cheyenne Guru Lee has been living with
her family inside a two-bedroom
apartment for the last three years but
she tells us over the last couple of
months several problems have been
happening including broken power outlets
and even having no power at all and all
this happening during the hottest time
of the year I mean right now I'm kind of
stuck Cheyenne gurulay says she's been
left in the dark literally
this one was doing nothing and then
there's this Outlet down here says her
apartment unit near Flamingo and Jones
has been having a series of issues over
the summer from broken power outlets to
having no power at all it was bad
um so sometimes when our power was
working our AC still wasn't working so
then me and my kids and my fiance or my
dog I put all of us into the same room
so I could put all of our fans from the
house in there after bringing up the
issue with management the repairs would
happen but the problem would happen
again complex staff she says told her
it's because the property is old and was
told her rent is going up they said it
goes from 1075 doesn't go to 1700 and
they're going to be adding water trash
and sewage which is another 150 on top
of that if I break my lease there's a
fee I don't know it's very stressful the
high rent cost around the valley gurulay
says is keeping her trapped in her unit
and the rent hike is keeping her up at
night I don't know how I would afford it
like there's no way according to Nevada
Legal Services there are options they
they tell us landlords are required to
keep properties in livable conditions if
any issues come up they recommend
tenants notify their landlord in writing
and certified for now this mother of two
says she just wants to enjoy her home
that's not livable we reached out to the
apartment complex's corporate office and
they tell us they have no comment about
this issue and gurulay tells us this
afternoon she still has no power now
Nevada Legal Services reminding all
tenants they do have options visit
8newsnow.com for all that information
Christian Casitas 8 News Now